got the movie career going you have a
new film that you just coming out paddle
tonight altered not having you confuse
the Tarleton know people that are still
about a bear that comes so it's a it's
you know it's a little heavy the theme
it's two guys who are friends and
they're kind of Outsiders they're little
they're socially awkward they don't
really connect with anybody else in the
world they have each other they're just
buddies they live in the same apartment
complex one of them gets terminally ill
and he wants to before he dies he has a
six monthly scent of life expectancy and
he decides to legally commit assisted
suicide and he wants me to help him when
he wants his best friend to help him
with it so that's yeah that's not that's
not the little bear that's not time
there is a movie where he did suicide
I went where the bear actually does the
suicide but it's also an improv movie
too which is cool that when I say an
improv movie he wrote an outline there
was like a twenty page out where there
was no script so each team would be
outlined and we would talk about it
before and then we would just do do the
scene so it's kind of like I don't know
that's how he does most of his movies
mark applause all over actually and so
it was a little dangerous a little scary
for me because I had never done that and
there was you're a planner you're a guy
that likes to figure it out and and you
know Mark littell so doing anal yeah but
you you very I think doing improv I
could see how it might be scary to you
but it looks like you have a lot of fun
I mean I the improv looking comedy I've
been product and all that but but the
for the dramatic scenes there was a
scene this is an interesting story I
mean it's a little bit of a spoiler but
it's you should still see the movie no
matter what at the end of the movie he
when he decides it's time so he has to
drink this thing and and so we talked
about the the death scene but we didn't
say what we were gonna do we just we
just discussed he'll drink it I lay on
the bed
and and and maybe you lay next to me and
then let's just do it and that's it we
went okay we started filming so we're
doing it filming with whom and it's and
it's dramatic and he he he drinks in and
he's going through it all the boom and
I'm laying next to him and all I all I
was told was after he dies
lie down take it all in leave the room
so we're doing it boom it's emotional he
dies I laid down I I let it all hit me
and he comes back to life
mark Duplass just like that and in my
head I'm like well that's an interesting
choice but I want to stay in the moment
right so I'm like I guess maybe he
thinks the medicine you convulse or
something so I we relive it again and
boom he dies and and I'm talking I mean
it's really emotional I laid back again
he comes up again and now I'm thinking
well this is we're gonna cut this in
editing right this is a horror movie
this is how horribly wrong he says
zombie and he lays down again and
finally I lay down uh the director was
filming it and I hear him whisper ray
leave the room leave the room so finally
I just get up I walk out I leave the
room and we cut and we come back in and
I try to jet you know
tactfully talk about it and he he wasn't
coming back to life he was holding his
breath to try to look dead and I was
taking too long together
that's it but I'm not saying he dies in
the movie no no no clearly not he dies
15 times you should see the movie all
right well we have a clip from paddle
tonigh think this is when you guys are
kind of in a road trip situation is that
correct weird we're driving to get to
find the drugs and there's only like
it's only legal in certain states so
we're on like a road trip a 6-hour road
trip to try to find the medication that
will do this yeah let's take a look at
this and it's just the stupid banter
that that happens okay well you just
undersold it let's let's take a look at
this yeah and it's really not it's
nothing to see yeah this is clip from
the talented how many wishes would a
genie have to give you wear one of those
wishes would be sand off let's and off
whenever you you said sand off every
grain of sand that was on your body
no all 1,200 maybe no 10 if they give me
10 do it you can only think of 9 wishes
where you get to sand off somebody you
need okay well your first one all the
cancers gone and a billion dollars the
flying whatever invisible invisible and
then say no yeah well pajamas on pajamas
it's late at night you talk for jamas on
Otakon and Ray Romano right here right
we said right right here around the
corner sorry are streaming globally on
Netflix I don't care where you are in
the world you can be watching those and
you're enjoying the stand-up as much as
ever you know now I have to write a
whole new Act yeah cuz you do that's
like once you do that you have to write
a whole new way yeah and it's got to be
true stuff I mean my family to do scrap
because I need yeah I always that's how
I write from true from truth you know I
know I don't know if we have time that's
really do well you know how comics
always say true story yeah
all of my bits start with something - I
stopped doing a bit once because I
thought I was being dishonest with the
audience a long time ago well right
after I got married I was doing a bit
about how sex slows down after marriage
and I told the audience you know what it
is for us the bit was like it's every
three months we don't plan it it's every
three months you know what I do every
time we have sex the next day I pay my
estimated tax my quarters are good right
so that was a bit and I was grossly
exaggerating yeah and I felt I'm lying
to the audience so I stopped doing it I
married 30 years now I caught up to the
bit
[Laughter]
[Applause]